speaking of intentional action
and if the brain is pre if prediction is
indeed
a core component of the brain let me ask
you a question that scientists also hate
is uh about free will so how does uh
do you think about free will much how
does that fit into this
into your view of the brain why does it
feel like
we make decisions in this world this is
a hard q a
scientists hate this because it's a hard
it's a hard question we don't really
take it aside
i think i have free will i think i have
taken aside but it
i don't put a lot of stock in
my own intuitions or anybody's
intuitions about the cause of things
right our ex one thing we know about the
brain for sure
is that the brain creates experiences
for us
my brain creates experiences for me your
brain creates experiences for you
in a way that lures you to believe that
those experiences
actually reveals the way that it works
right but it doesn't
so so you don't trust your own intuition
about
not really not really no i mean no but
but i am also somewhat persuaded by you
know i think dan dennett wrote at one
point like
um uh you know the philosopher dan
dennett wrote at one point that
um it it's i can't say it as eloquently
as him but it
people obviously have free will they are
obviously making choices so
it's you know and so there is this
observation
that we're not robots and we can do some
things like a little more sophisticated
than an amphioxus so
um so here's what i would say i would
say
that your predictions your
internal model that's running right now
right that your ability to understand
the sounds that i'm making and attach
them to ideas
is based on the fact that you
have years of experience knowing what
these sounds mean
in a particular statistical uh
pattern right i mean that's how you can
understand
the words that are coming out of my
mouth right i think we did this once
before too didn't we when we were
i don't know i would have to access my
memory module i think when i was in your
glen yeah i think we did it just like
that actually so bravo
wow yeah i have to go look look back to
the tape
yeah anyways the um the idea though
is that your brain is using past
experience and it can
and it can use past experience in um
so it's remembering but you're not
consciously remembering it's basically
re-implementing
prior experiences as a way of predicting
what's going to happen next
and it can do something called
conceptual combination which is it can
take bits and pieces
of the past and combine it in new ways
so you
can experience and make sense of
things that you've never encountered
before because you've encountered
something
similar to them
and so a brain in a sense
is not just
doesn't just contain information it is
information gaining
meaning it can create it new information
by this generative process so in a sense
you could say well that maybe that's
that's a source of free will but i think
really where free will comes from or the
kind of free will that i think is worth
having a conversation about is um
involves cultivating experiences for
yourself
that change your internal model
when you were born and you were raised
in a particular
context that your mod your brain wired
itself
to your surroundings to your physical
surroundings and also to your social
surroundings
so you were handed an internal model
basically
um but uh when you grow up
the more control you have over your
where you are and what you do um
you can cultivate new experiences for
yourself and those new experiences
can change your internal model and you
can actually
practice those experiences in a way
that makes them automatic meaning it
makes it easier for the brain
your brain to make them again and
i think that that is something like
what you would call free will you aren't
responsible
for the model that you were handed that
someone you know your your caregivers
uh cultivated a model in your brain
you're not responsible for that model
but you are responsible for the one you
have now
you can choose you choose what you
expose yourself to
you choose uh how you spend your time
not everybody has choice over everything
right but everybody
has a little bit of choice um and
and so i think that is
uh something that i i think is arguably
called free will
yeah there's this like the the ripple
effects
of the billions of decisions you make
early on in life
have are so great
that uh even if it's not
even if it's like all deterministic just
the amount of possibilities that are
created and then the focusing of those
possibilities into a single trajectory
uh that somewhere within that that's
free will
even if it's all deterministic that
might as well be
of just the number of choices that are
possible and the fact that you just make
one trajectory to those set of choices
seems to be like something like they'll
be called free will
but it's still kind of sad to think like
there doesn't seem to be a place where
there's magic in there
or it is all just a computer well
there's lots of magic
i would say so far because we don't
really understand
uh how all of this is exactly
played out at a
i mean scientists are working hard and
disagree about some of the details
under the hood of what i just described
but
i think there's quite a bit of magic
actually and also there's
there's also um stochastic
firing of neurons don't they
they're not purely digital in the sense
that
there is there's also analog
communication between neurons not just
digital
so it's not just with not just with
firing of axons
and some of that uh there's there are
other ways to communicate
and also um uh
there's noise in the system and the
noise is there
for a really good reason and that is um
the more variability there is the more
potential there is for your brain to
be able to be information bearing so
um basically you know there are some
animals that have
clusters of cells the only job is to
inject noise
you know into their um neural patterns
so maybe noise is the source of free
will
so you can think about you can think
about stochasticity or noise as
as a source of free will or you can
think of
of um conceptual combination as a
source of free will you can certainly
think about
cultivating uh you know you can't
reach back into your past and change
your past
you know people try by psychotherapy and
so on but
what you can do is change your present
um which becomes your past
right think about that sentence so one
way to think about it is that you're
continuously this is a colleague of mine
a friend of mine said
so what you're saying is that people are
continually cultivating their past
and i was like that's very poetic yes
you are continually cultivating your
past
as a means of controlling your future
so you think uh yeah i guess the the
construction of the mental model that
you use for prediction
ultimately contains within it your
perception of the past like the way
you interpret the past or even just the
entirety of your narrative about the
past
so you're constantly rewriting the story
of your past
oh boy yeah that's one poetic and also
just awe-inspiring
you